- A poetic form congenial
to Robert Browning.
So it's kind of a form
that was good to him,
that worked well for him.
A poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue.
It let him explore a character's mind
without the simplifications demanded
by stage productions.
So just the way I read it,
I had more pause here than just a comma.
If I really read it
actually with the comma,
it would have been "A
poetic form congenial
"to Robert Browning was
the dramatic monologue,
"it let him explore a character's mind
"without the simplifications demanded by
"stage productions."
This is really kind of
a separate expression
right over here.
It really demands more pause.
I would think about,
instead of a comma here,
you could put a period there,
kind of a full stop.
Or maybe a semi-colon, which says,
well it's a little bit in between.
It's a related thought,
but we're gonna pause a little bit more.
So I would put at least
a semi-colon there,
if not a period.
So let's see what else they put over here.
A poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue--
Okay, well, obviously this was as is.
We already said that we
don't really like that one.
A poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologe,
which let him explore a
character's mind without
the simplifications demanded
by stage productions.
Actually this one works pretty well,
because now it's not a separate
statement right over here.
Here, we have this
relative pronoun "which",
and you have the dependent clause,
so it's really telling us more about
why he, the dramatic
monologue was a poetic form
congenial to Robert Browning.
So because it's not an
independent statement,
it actually works well with a comma.
Here, I don't feel the
need to put a period
or a semi-colon.
So this is actually a pretty good,
this is actually a pretty good solution.
But let's look at the other ones.
A poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue that lets him
explore a character's mind without the
simplifications demanded
by stage productions.
So this feels, when
they're using "that" here,
it feels much more like they're telling us
a certain type of dramatic monologue.
So not just all dramatic monologues,
but it was in particular
the dramatic monologue
that lets him explore a character's mind.
But we're not saying that that's the only
type of dramatic monologue.
We're saying all dramatic monologues
let him explore a character's mind
without the simplifications demanded by
stage productions.
That's what a dramatic monologue is,
it's just someone talking
without other stuff
really going on and all
this other fancy stuff.
So this, to me, see, kind of changes
the meaning of it.
It doesn't, it's not wrong grammatically.
A dramatic monologue that lets him explore
a character's mind.
But it's changing the meaning.
It's saying, it feels like it's qualifying
the type of dramatic monologue.
But the intention of the sentence is
that all, that the reason why it was,
that dramatic monologues are
good for Robert Browning,
are that all dramatic monologues
let him explore a character's mind without
the simplifications demanded
by stage productions.
So I'll rule this one out.
I'll kind of, a weak scratch out.
It's not, you know,
it's just kind of changing the meaning.
So let's get these other ones.
A poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue, semi-colon,
letting him explore a character's mind
without the simplifications demanded
by stage productions.
So they're giving me the semi-colon that I
kind of wanted in the beginning,
but then they're making this into,
it's not no longer, the second,
what we have after that is no longer
kind of an independent phrase like it was,
or an independent almost clause,
like it was before.
Now we're saying letting him explore...
This actually would have felt
better with a comma here.
So I'm gonna throw this one out.
A poetic form congenial to Robert Browning
was the dramatic monologue
by letting him do--
So this one was dramatic monlogue,
and then we immediately go into "by".
By letting him do exploration.
So this was, I guess, how
the dramatic monologue...
But once again, B is much clearer
in that they're saying
the dramatic monologue,
which, which is referring
to the dramatic monologue,
lets him explore a character's mind.
So I'd rule this one out.
This one actually is quite awkward
in the way it's phrased.